now we're going to create a
sample application that
takes our list of friends and
allows us to give gifts to them
we start by making small
modifications to the xml file
creating a form that has a list
of friends and a list of gifts
and a button to give
the gift to the friend
next we modify our on Load
friends function
so instead of listing
the friends on the page
it creates a menu out of them
so we can pick one friend
next we create another function
make options menu
which takes the list of gifts that
we specify and creates
it into a menu so that we can
select a gift to give to our friend.
then we modify our
initialization function
so that instead of just
loading our friends
it also loads the gift menu when
the gadget loads
the last and most important step
is writing the give gift function.
this function takes the gift and
the friend  we wish to send the
gift to and saves them in to the
persistent data storage
of the open social API
we do that by creating
a new data request object
and passing into it a new
update person APP data request
specifying to save the data
under the viewer object.
then we send the request to the
open social API
which stores the data
Here you can see our gadget in
action
specifying a list of gifts
a list of friends and a button
to give a gift to the friend
for more information
on what i just showed you
check out the tutorial on
"code.google.com"
under the open social section